yesterday we talked about the
establishment Democratic campaign to
stop Bernie Sanders that is taking place
in some establishment enclaves of the
upper echelons of the Democratic Party
there's a very very good New York Times
report about this which we discussed
yesterday meetings about the quote
Bernie problem discussions of how Bernie
Sanders maybe could be stopped and
yesterday we focused in on two parts of
this question one is is there actually a
Democratic establishment movement to
stop Bernie Sanders and the question to
is why would the establishment Democrats
want to stop Bernie Sanders I'm not
going to redo that because we did it
yesterday but in response to the New
York Times article there have been a
bunch of different commentaries written
arguing that this establishment movement
might exist but that it is not going to
work in 2020 the way it did in 2016 and
there are some really interesting
commentaries which assert that because
the dynamics in 2020 with Bernie are so
different than they were in 2016 if
establishment Democrats want to stop
Bernie Sanders that it's actually going
to be very difficult and my question to
you as we talk it through is whether
this is accurate or whether this is
naive and I'll explain what I mean one
such article is by Jim Newell who wrote
a piece for Slate called the paradox of
the Democratic stop Bernie campaign and
what Jim Newell is asserting is that the
reason all of these meetings are taking
place and that the establishment is more
and more concerned about Bernie Sanders
is because they realized that it's going
to be a lot tougher to stop him this
time around than it was in 2016 a newel
says that in talking to professional
democrats about the stop Bernie movement
that the New York Times says is
developing they don't deny that it
exists but many high highly placed
Democratic operatives are saying it's
not going to work it's not 2016 that if
Bernie keeps the polling lead if bernie
keeps raising money the way he's been
raising money if Bernie does well in the
debates if Bernie grabs some early
primaries like Iowa caucuses and the new
HAMP
primary that the Democratic
establishment is actually not going to
be able to do that much to stop Bernie
Sanders there's a second article which I
suggest you read which is in the New
Republic and it's called the impotence
of the stop Sanders Democrats and it
also is saying that a lot of this effort
to stop Bernie if it exists to the
extent that exist it exists is futile
and that it might actually backfire and
help Bernie Sanders and if you go down
this path you eventually get to what can
the sort of democratic ruling class
actually do to Bernie Sanders this time
around let's talk through the options
they could pour money into anti Bernie
attack ads the difference is that in
2016 the anti Bernie stuff was
concentrated in the Pro Hillary camp
right now the anti Bernie push would be
pretty split between other candidates
and that's one reason why it may not
work so well something else that the
establishment Democrats could do maybe
they could rally the big Democratic
donors against Bernie Sanders but again
rally against Bernie and for who because
if the big Democratic donors don't agree
who is it we're going to support pouring
money into two three or four different
Democratic alternatives to Bernie it's
not really gonna hurt Bernie very much
it's actually gonna split money while
Bernie continues fundraising so I think
there is a very fair question here of
what can be done to hurt Bernie Sanders
in this campaign could something be done
around the debates to hurt Bernie
Sanders I don't even really know so the
idea that a bunch of people on the Left
are pushing is that the cat is sort of
out of the bag with Bernie and that it's
going to be hard to damage him in the
way that attempts were made to damage
him in 2016 so where am I on this I
don't for a second believe that it will
be as easy to smear Bernie as it was in
2016 at least not effectively but there
are things that the Democratic Party
could do to hurt Bernie Sanders loyalty
oaths
laid into Burnie caucusing with
Democrats but not being a Democrat being
an independent that's one possibility
trying to close some primaries to keep
independent progressives from voting and
restricting it only to register
Democrats it would be very noticeable
and attract a lot of attention but it
could be done
Riaan vicar invigorates some of those
super delegate rules that they got rid
of since 2016 which could potentially
hurt Bernie Sanders
I don't think Pat at this point that
that is likely to happen I think the
Democratic establishment if they want to
hurt Bernie what they really need to do
is very soon determine who it is that
they are going to unify behind if it's
Joe Biden if he decides to run if it's
Pete Budaj if it's Kamala Harris and to
be clear Pat I'm not giving the damaged
Democratic anti Bernie establishment
advice on what to do I'm merely saying
if they want to do damage to Bernie
Sanders they probably need to pick one
horse and ride it all the way to the
finish line pretty soon that's exactly
right and this situation reminds me so
much of the 2016 Republican primaries
because the establishment didn't want
Donald Trump but they didn't know
exactly who to put their support behind
like maybe they went with Jeb Bush at
first but then it became clear that Bush
wasn't their guy and then they switched
over to Marco Rubio and then that fell
through and then they went to Kasich and
Cruz when you have so many people
running it's hard to pick one candidate
in particular and I think that's exactly
what's gonna happen with this race
because they're what 1520 Democratic
candidates in the field and I think
what's really important to understand is
even though there is something as Pat
points out that is similar between
what's going on now and what happened in
2016 with the Republican primary the
Democratic primary experiencing that
same thing is going to be much more
damaging to the eventual Democratic
candidate than what happened in the 2016
Republican primary was to Donald Trump
because in the end those Republicans saw
Hillary Clinton as the enemy and even if
they were Kasich Republicans even if
they were Rubio Republicans whatever
overwhelmingly they were still going to
go and vote for Trump because they
didn't want Hillary Clinton to win the
left is obviously very anti Trump but I
think that an equivalent situation
of internal sniping again in 2020 within
the Democratic primary will actually do
some damage that could potentially allow
Donald Trump to be re-elected to another
four years because some people will be
so disgusted they'll decide not to vote
some people will be so disgusted that
they will vote third party I'm not
saying I agree with them doing that but
what I'm telling you is that it will
happen so the Democratic Left needs to
be very careful about how they manage
this primary send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I
definitely want to hear from you about
this if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video